the Walnut Tree Inn is in trouble
[Music]
in Wales the head chefs quit and the
kitchen's a joke
even with that hairstyle you're still
not a cockroach the customers have fled
and the owner's so broke he's headed to
sell his house so he's asked me to help
him out but I've only got one week to
find out what's happened and turn things
around you shut
the show the owner where he's going
wrong welcome back
where the [__] have you been and do
everything I can to help him and if he
doesn't cut his prices then listen well
quite frankly he's on his own [__] it
oh
hundreds of restaurants open in Britain
every year but over two-thirds close in
the first 12 months the walnut tree in
abergavenny has been one of Britain's
most famous restaurants for nearly 40
years set in beautiful Welsh Countryside
it's the proud holder of a covered
admission star
to this man Franco teruccio he was one
of the first celebrity chefs three years
ago Francesco matioli another Italian
who bought the walnuts
guys
so he should know what he's doing I've
come to find out how in just three years
he's managed to mess it all up
how are you how are you all right well
you're losing weight again no I'm not
losing weight what's the smallest
numbers you've done in three years you
see is it for lunch for dinner once it
was a Thursday night
supposedly
and
yeah that was bad
every kitchen just has to have a head
chef running it since Francesco lost his
he's been trying to do the job himself
I'll take this you're gonna serve it yes
because Jesus
cook serve cook serve cook serve
[Music]
it's a big mistake Francesco is not a
trained chef and he shouldn't even be in
the kitchen
keep on going he should be out in the
dining room Charming his customers
after all there are more staff in the
bloody kitchen than there are customers
in the dining room and not one of them
seems to be doing anything so you're
just cooking potatoes here yeah there's
huge section and all your cooking is
spuds you're out of order yes
Frances Jessica doesn't trust anyone to
do anything right Bill only 11 and 12
right now
octopus
another tree said
ciao all the best thank you very much
talk about headless chicken no wonder
he's lost weight and customers you're
working like a donkey I mean you're here
everywhere and trying to run it
overall you know the most amazing house
you can charm the pants off anyone and
you can sell good wine and the short
period of time I've been in here today
and one thing you know I've come to
terms with is it's got to get out of the
kitchen
the walnut tree got a mission staff
Francesca had been here for a year
that's given to a restaurant on the back
of the consistency the freshers of the
ingredients keeping it seasonal and the
individual Flair of the chef
but Francesca's lost the chef who won
the award if the standards have slipped
inspectors will soon take away that
precious Michelin star
time to check out the food because I saw
lunch today from the kitchen
I'm gonna go in the dining room now
and have a bite to eat
and I'd like you not to present the menu
but to show me three dishes
what represents the walnut tree in
with a Michelin star you can charge
top-notch prices but only if you provide
top-notch food I'm pretty confidently
porcini and palm ham lasagna was always
a favorite here boy
very important
you've got to move on you've got to
search something you've got to evolve
develop and create excitement constantly
when you're charging these prices
but the muscles haven't even been
cleaned when you serve mussels in a
self-contained stew yeah they've got to
be clean because when you're serving
them
there's a lot of grit
sand so it's just like eating a bowl of
clay
seasoned with sand
that is constantly grinding between your
teeth 28 pound the main course
because if someone served that in my
mission I'd go [__] berserk okay
um I asked you earlier for your best
the best the best of Wales the big build
up was for the classic Italian fish stew
and sadly when it arrived everything in
that dish was overcooked
and why are you piss off for a
three-hour break
to style your hair and have a kit and
clean the [__] muscles so we've hit
rock bottom okay yeah Welcome to the
Real World tomorrow
I'm gonna pick ourselves back up
start off with a clean slate
[Music]
my second day in Wales where I'm trying
to help the owner say the famous Walnut
Tree Restaurant it's got all sorts of
problems but it does still have a
Michelin star you don't get that without
a top chef but Francesca's lost his we
need to find another one fast head chef
criteria action criteria young
enthusiastic ambition ambition yeah
someone would keep you out of the
kitchen so just ride something that
keeps me out of the kitchen and uh hello
Ross okay Mr Ramsey we've got a list of
ingredients we're just going to ask you
to go through and cook up something very
simple yeah thanks for the surprise
it's all right always a surprise with me
starting starting salary
always an interesting question when you
interview a young chef what style are
you looking for
and then yeah sell you within 30 seconds
of course yeah what they're about what
would you be happy with as a starting
salary
I'd be happy with
you we're 30. 30 is the starting salary
[__] off out of it
do you want me to drive it or do you
know how to write English
no you're probably I think he's better
than me yeah well I'll write it down you
phone it through but you pay for it okay
it's expensive
but it's very hard just to go in there
and just cook
um 15 minutes yeah yeah it's interesting
to see if he uses all the ingredients
whether he puts the clams with a hat up
with
um the onions or just a nice tomato a
rocket salad yeah
something plain and simple your mother
could make that
eating raw pasta
yeah boy it's all kind of thing I've
spent the message to do yeah I thought
it was a little bit Plain Jane boring
and certainly not worth 30 grand a year
that's for sure no but like it
that's the ingredients you were given
but don't start blaming your tools no no
no no no
take it on the channel I wanted to
change it now
next up is santoroso second in command
at the Holiday Inn in Swindon to be a
bandito it could be a big bandito
let's shoot the bandito what do you
think
Santo go take a seat
um very well experienced man yeah yeah I
like cooking you like cooking yeah I can
see that yeah what'd you know about the
walnut tree nothing nothing at all
nothing at all don't know about the
history
reputation yeah the Michelin star no no
so
what
if you don't know anything about the
walnut tree yeah why did you come for
the job
because it's time for me to change right
um and what's the current menu at the
Swindon we have some steak Yeah Gammon
chicken
and a lot of microwave a lot of
microwave microwave microwave
think of something magical keep it
simple oh yeah
um and enjoy it okay thank you
[Music]
and what I'm thinking wow what kind of
flavor I wanna
I want to come up with
and let's see
[Music]
I thought you were a joke like that can
cook
very rare
[Music]
these are fantastic work
and just explain what they are please
yes this is a I call it Pasta Fresca
Pasta Fresca Pasta Fresca fresh pasta
where vulgari and salad
thank you with the lemon juice just nice
and clean
so that is prepared black pepper yeah
thank you Joe thank you very much felt
like sneezing in all that stuff
Jesus Christ
no it's just kind of starch
there's nothing in there is that
you said
you're too sad to see some there's also
foreign
I found it yeah miles away from what we
wanted yeah
yeah and um a little bit embarrassing
really yeah because it was below average
yeah
22 000 pound and I wouldn't even pay him
23 000 lira
even with the Michelin star it's going
to be hard to find a head chef in the
middle of Wales but I'm still Banning
Francesca from the kitchen right now
wasting water where's Francesca I really
would appreciate it if you don't come
anywhere near the kitchen I know how
stubborn you are
I'm dare step over that line stay that
size
thank you
[Music]
this way I'll get to know the team
better blakey's the most Junior he's
just come off the building site because
the weather's too cold
Spike he's here on work experience
Kevin's a waiter and handyman he's been
here since the old days I knew the
walnut tree and it's Prime hello Kevin
hello good morning obviously with that
accent local boy from abergavenny Yes
uh no I just you know just love hard
work definitely evil
Gary's a local boy very ambitious and
Keen to get on but Francesco says he's
not a team player
so that's my secret I'll state that
round there put a padlock on that
[Music]
and Stefan is the most experienced Chef
Francesca won't let him run the kitchen
but I want to see what he's made of so
I'm going to put him in charge it's a
normal lunch service and Francesco's
wife Enrique has brought some friends in
for a bite to eat
you're gonna start
talking about turn around and dress the
Brigade
that's it
one chicken plus chips for four kids one
crab one and dive to follow one loyal
loan of pork to chicken or one rocket
hey
I need some chips
for the Kings yeah
the only person here now is Gary and
you're one in the kitchen let's go okay
the honest blankie by the first flaky
yes
I wonder Francesca's back in the kitchen
his family are still waiting for their
lunch
everything's out there now
everyone's standing staring at their
food and two people haven't got it
come on
come on Steph let's go this is a [__]
disaster
okay chicken how long
Stephano Hello Cheers yeah do you know
right it's for the boss's wife you know
that
if it's Stone Cold yeah get another one
in
hey he owns the place and I'm not going
to serve that let's go
look for the chicken curry
chicken ready let's go bring it together
then let's go
nice note this time
send it
the food is late and cold stefana can't
organize chips for a four-year-old okay
right come here just stop everybody yeah
I mean stop come here you come here shut
up
shut up I'm talking
that was a disaster complete disaster
the food's standing hanging around the
past nothing happening and you're over
there and then just I'm sorry but it's
not good enough you're not nothing's
coming out okay stop now okay you take
over and see if we can pull ourselves
together a little bit and get ourselves
out of the ship because in 15 minutes
this place is gonna be the biggest
[__] in Wales you shut it okay back
in your corner and listen to what's
going on do you know what I said yeah do
it right let's go a little clear down
yeah play down first
okay Gary know where we are yes
and the brill and decide exactly what
you want doing in your mind two minutes
before we dress you turn around and
dress the Brigade and tell them exactly
what you want yeah yeah uh one braised
beef one venison sausage one Grill one
tuna away
let's keep it together Hey where's the
team and I don't want to back in here
because we can't [__] do it again
okay so a bit of teamwork now yeah if
you can't hear you then then spoon for
that okay because we're not a one-man
band
[Music]
Gary is a real arrogant little [__]
but at least he can speak unlike Stefano
they can't even run a [__] bath let
alone a [__] kitchen I need the tuna
baked first off you please
please
well done good
okay well done well done okay main
course he's bloody difficult to get out
like that you know Well Done yes
how'd it go for you another one thank
you for being honest I thought it went
terrible
huh
really bad you really do have a problem
talking to individuals you know that and
today was a disaster
yeah
I'm sorry it really was a disaster
if you ever get your own Russian one day
make sure you haven't got any more than
[__] five seats because you won't be
able to manage you know that
and so we've got to Now work on this the
next couple of days and stop you being a
cook and look at
the important role of becoming a chef
[Music]
still problems in the kitchen I just
don't understand why there's so few
customers
[Music]
these days they serve around 300
customers a week the previous owner
Franco used to serve 800. I'd love to
know what happened to the missing 500.
have you heard of them on a tree yes
when was the last time you were there it
was Franco's last meal just before we
work
yeah
have you ever heard the walnut tree it's
overpriced overpriced
and how many times are you there oh very
very frequently when he was there
because he was open all hours you turn
over at 11 o'clock at night and be
assured of a very good welcome I think
he's missed now now he's no longer there
I think so they're not as good
not recently since it's been taken over
now since Francesca took over the walnut
tree nine new restaurants have opened
nearby if people think his place is too
expensive they've got plenty of cheaper
alternatives morning ladies so we've
been there when Franco it seems to be
everyone's favorite in Epic of any
Franco and Anne they always seem to be
the Darlings of abergavenny yet no one's
been since Francesca took over three
years ago
maybe there's a lesson to be learned if
your customers won't pay top whack cut
your prices otherwise they'll eat
elsewhere
and you come down the platification
where you think Jesus there's that
typing error 70 quid it is somewhat a
little bit intimidating because it's so
expensive which puts people off
and have we gone up in price over the
last three years have we got more and
more expensive yeah
was 55 60 16.
and then I push it to 65 and only in the
last two months I put it to 70. because
the price of the fish is going up and up
as usual Francesca thinks he knows best
but I won't give him a bulletin in front
of his team anyway just now I've got
other fish to fry
there's still no head chef so far I
think Stefano and Gary are the best
candidates
but Francesco just won't consider them
he's got to be realistic he's in the
middle of Wales not London
straightforwards and if you don't find
anyone as good as Gary we don't find
anyone as good as Stefano then you know
we're going to look at what we've got
internally
well
well no I think that I think we need
somebody really from outside inside it
internally I can only be the one
Francesco just doesn't see it but Gary
and Stefano have talent and I'm going to
show him the only way I'll get him to
try their food is to make him believe
that I've cooked it really important
tomorrow night yeah big night for you
doesn't believe that you're capable of
becoming the chef I think you are it's
your half hour so have you thought about
your dishes
think of an oyster starting with like a
herb crusty Grotto on the top for a main
course I was singing a meat of some sort
like a fillet with some some shallots so
important we'll do service then at the
end of service we'll sit them down and
bang you let rip sure [__] you let Rick
big time uh right Stefano let's go
yeah
the crap in the kitchen about the
delegation the lack of Direction yeah we
can work on that that's workable but
this is your half hour
of magic all right
think about it yeah and and make sure
you utilize that time and come up with
something magical they will sit him down
for dinner and we'll say eat the
following this is me this is me on a
plate yeah right hard on material
how do you say you're actually Italian
correction
the money okay that's it that's it
alexione [__] me post words of an
erection
as well as preparing their meals Gary
and Stefano must do their normal kitchen
duties straight away Stefano starts
working with the team but Gary He's only
interested in his own meal
even I think that's too ambitious
hi Gary
two seconds
you've had a bit more time on your hands
this morning to get ready yes and he
hasn't done anything for tonight so we
swap over yeah yeah okay okay so once
all this vegetables cooked then I want
you in the kitchen concentrate on
tonight's service concentrate on the
calipers for tomorrow night yeah and
then you take
two hours
yeah enough yeah yeah two hours they
organized for tonight okay
I really thought Gary had great
potential to be a good head chef but
quite honestly doesn't give a [__] about
his team he just cares about himself
and selfish individuals don't make great
head chefs
[Music]
Francesco and Enrico think I'm the chef
tonight the Gary stefana haven't
prepared it'll be my reputation that
suffers
cheese parmesan cheese parsley yeah
and Steph what have you got
[Music]
um
it's not a competition tool number silly
okay inside is what the Duncan Chestnut
chestnuts yeah
Stefano's duck and Chestnut ravioli
shows real imagination
no I like the um
sweet if you feel you can taste
something sweet that's nice it's
Chestnut
I like the whisper sandwiches and
Francesco approves of Gary's oysters
it's very nice
Gary yeah look so far so good clean
place for me it's a sign of yeah
happiness yes it's things like it's good
[Music]
for the main course there is called
filled steak and Stefano sea bass nice
both you well done
puppy
a lot of them happy yeah
all right go Kevin where we do don't
drop those
okay well done guys yes I like the
colors I'm sure I like the taste
okay
um Stefano you ready with the pancakes
you're happy now aren't you hey I've
never seen so happy yeah it's about
Bloody time huh
hi guys
okay
yes supper supper I really like the
ravioli Optical Chestnut yes
um
and I liked everything else interesting
for me yes I would say most of the
dishes were exciting I was interested in
the India ravioli and again I found it
exciting and very good very nicely done
and the beef and the beef uh I would
have like a half a doofinoise underneath
the beef some form of potatoes potatoes
that would have banged the dishes up and
balance it out uh don't take this the
wrong way but I didn't cook any dish all
right
oysters beef sorbet yeah what's his menu
24 hours ago yes
Doug ravioli sea bass and pancakes with
Stefanos and because they weren't been
interviewed during the week because I
think Francesco doesn't think they're
good enough I wanted them to cook three
dishes each for you both have dinner
tonight so I didn't touch anything thank
you very much Steve for your comments
thank you
okay uh generally two seconds
um well that was interesting tonight
yeah all the dishes that you both done
they said was capable of going on the
menu oh great because for me it went
very well both of you came up trumps and
if he wasn't going to continue for the
job then I was yeah
good
it's day four I'm halfway through my
time at the walnut tree Francesco the
owner has been stubbornly resisting my
suggestions we still need to find a head
chef and with a 70 pound main course on
the menu I'm determined to make him
lower his prices if it continues being
as quiet as it is
are you going to look to try and bring
the prices down a touch to create
something new about the woman tree to
get people back in here
not the one I go down on on the cheap
side because
but everybody is a [__] Choice I'm
not talking about asking you to open the
doors and become a happy eater they
spend 37 years getting the business to
where it is today of course you're
spending three years and it's sadly on
the decline what I'm trying to say is
you bring a new traffic coming through
the door and you tweak the prices to
establish the confidence and once you've
got the confidence then over a period of
five or six years yes you turn the
volume up on the justification of what
you're doing I'm not convinced I always
say I'm not convinced I'm sorry it's me
you shouldn't be so stolen try it
if you've got the food and those custom
customers are coming through the door
and they're generating sales the asset
is the one it's the wife which who can
sell that me excellent so the chances
are far greater to do it that way than
to do it the way you're doing it
currently
anyway yes yes [__] Hallelujah
welcome back
where the [__] have you been what
happened
please try it well I do I'll do it man
please no problem thank you God
Francesco's finally agreed to one of my
ideas
and there's more good news at last a
candidate for the head Chef's job with a
good pedigree well yeah and you're
feeling at the age of 26 that you've
worked and the last two establishments
as a sous chef you're now ready for your
first head Chef's job yeah I'm I'm sort
of getting to the point where I'm in the
kitchen and I've got my own ideas that
the way I want to run things
um okay obviously some butter mushrooms
rocket Gorgonzola green mustard garlic
fresh um technically parmesan cheese see
you in 15 minutes thank you Spencer
bed of tomato salad the tagatelli of
mushroom sort of like carbonara almost
the linguine and I'm thinking like a
light Rockford and
um rocket salad
if I've got time
I don't expect anybody to come in in the
12 minutes and shower the timer
Spencer Ralph has traveled all the way
from London this would be his first head
Chef's job but he has worked in the
mission starred restaurant
[Music]
yeah yes I like the idea of being 26
someone young someone vibrant someone
you can push yeah definitely so so at 26
if if it's not hungry now when he's
never going to be here
thank you it's a rocket and tomato salad
with mushroom carbonara
and poached haddock thank you very much
it looks neat yeah yeah
it looks nice it's not um it looks
beautifully cooked it's not stuck
together it's not conjured
he's listening to the brief
it's kept it simple yeah yeah what it
has shown in the last 15 minutes the guy
can cook no the flavors are there Focus
are there exactly that sit down
how do you feel running the
establishment with a Michelin star
it's a little bit daunting you know to
do it the first time yeah a little bit
but I'm also you know it's what I've
always sort of aimed for it's always
what I wanted you know and I sort of
felt confident as well as scared at the
same time thank you very much thank you
I hope Spencer accepts the job if you
can start work soon there's a slim
chance the walnut tree can save its
Michelin star
almost everyone is looking happier and
it's so important to find the right
person to gel with those two guys
especially Gary all right because there
you've got one little ballsy Rottweiler
that really wants this job and you're
not prepared to give them the
opportunity
I hope we found a great head chef
now I want to change the atmosphere in
the dining room it's too cold and formal
we need to bring back some of the rustic
charm that people loved in the old days
let's hope Francesco agrees it's the
first reaction I would say no but
flexible
in the kitchen I want to see more energy
and we'll get up and go stay on Focus so
when Gary wants to say something to you
you're up here listening ready to say
yes or no not on the floor cockroaches
live on the floor you're not a [__]
cockroach even with that hairstyle
you're still not a cockroach hang on
shallots in first
lightning Seasons everyone needs to know
when the food's good enough to leave the
kitchen even Blakey
I thought he takes nothing much time
cooking in our microwave like an
absolute [__] donkey but not cool you
won't actually tasting anything you're
just pressing buttons taking that output
onto the plate it's got the mission
style this establishment you're gonna
have to learn how to taste pop in
understand what a balance of flavor is
about we're gonna make a chef at you you
know
if it kills me we're gonna make a
shepher you know that good how the [__]
out I don't know I'm thinking about it
now yeah
Kevin's been here years so he can tell
me if the atmosphere is more like it
used to be
uh this looks nice and just breaking it
up and it's not just a dull in yeah less
starches it's been like it for years
that's clearly have you done any oh yeah
yes yes yep
um apparently people used to come for
lunch and stay for hours spending even
more money we need to get back that
relaxed family feeling ah God what a
difference big difference and cozy which
is the most important thing and that's
what was missing yeah more welcome looks
fantastic Kevin's done a great job
redecorating we need one last touch to
restore those old traditions if
Francesca will agree to it and you know
I think the entrance needs a picture of
you and Franco
no the whole generation passed onto the
the new generation I think Francesca's
finally seen the light
day six and despite the hangovers it's
straight back to business
today's a big day the walnut tree is 40
years old this month and Francesco's
thrown a party
I think you should invite Franco and
Anne the previous owners
they're a vital part of the restaurant's
history
there is one thing I want you to do for
me yes which you're not going to like I
know you're not gonna lie because you're
going to disagree but I really think
it's important
um I want you to bring Franco back and I
want you to talk to him
I can see already in your face you don't
want to do it I don't have to say
anything my inspiration says it says
everything I do the first minute Frankie
walks in here little Silence of rumors
and it'll cut the [__] out and it
will start encouraging the locals to
come back the message is telling him
that you want to maintain what he's
built that's what I'm fighting for
I'm fighting for the reputation of the
world on three more than mine
thank you
Franco and M we're here for 37. yes
Francesca's been here for three 37 plus
three years 40. yeah massive celebration
huge celebration 40 Years of History yes
I'm going to put it back on the map lift
it and alongside that I think it's 80 or
90 yes coming along we have really nice
exciting canopies
can you Cornell
give me an answer straight away don't
take two weeks nothing nice but not that
nice we're gonna learn again right watch
as quick as you can in Twisted screen
rounds down
classic
okay
[Music]
a little bit too much on that
again again oh over the last few days
I've realized that Stefano is really
talented it's a shame he's just so shy
that's good that's very good right guys
[Applause]
in and out again so far Stefano's
beating you on the other hand Gary
thinks he's a dog's bottoms but he's not
nearly as good a cook
[Music]
now you can cook your heart out your
hair is perfect all nice and spiky and
all the girls never be ready still want
to Shag you
tonight's party is make or break for
Francesco he's on the Virgil going bust
and he must start filling the Russian
again
a bit you know it's obviously it's going
to be a very emotional evening for for
me and the rest of the day
customer that is going to come here and
for one especially and work it I work
there it's your place this time and
you're proud to show this off
after all these yes
Francesca's invited 80 of the great and
good of that big of any
everyone's just got to love everything
and if they tell all the friends the
food is as good as ever then Francesco
could soon serve 800 people a week just
like the good old days right just
running through me running through me
what were that ricotta
[Music]
yeah
what's the feedback we're all overnight
they're all amazing
we've all been waiting for Franco and
Anne to arrive hopefully this will prove
that Francesco is carrying on the
Traditions they established at the
walnut tree
I would love to but as I'm going out to
dinner tonight
[Laughter]
thank you
[Music]
I'm very glad that you came here
both of you and to celebrate this
special event
for both of us
thank you for all of us thank you very
much should we do it together yes happy
birthday happy birthday
[Music]
[Applause]
it's been a terrific night I just hope
it marks the start of the Walnut tree's
Revival
wouldn't have happened and I really
appreciate your
hard work thank you thank you thank you
on my final day another breakthrough
Spencer's accepted the head Chef's job
okay Spencer thank you very much indeed
bye bye for now
and he sounded excited yes very much so
yes and I'm excited too fantastic that's
quite uh refreshing it's a relief yeah
yeah I was very happy very happy
good
there's only one more thing Francesca
needs to sort out with Spencer arriving
as head chef there can only be one
second Chef Stefano or Gary one can stay
but one must go Gary's so ambitious I'm
not sure he'd give Spence the support he
needs how would you feel if you're
brought in a new head chef now
well I mean I could say before I'm not
upset about it but um if Francesco feels
the need to do it then I'm glad you're
going to learn for whoever comes in if
they've got someone to teach me but then
again if if they if they're no good or
if they're just a store or awkward I'm
just gonna push on and still get ahead
of them and prove him wrong pretty much
and so even if a new Chef came in I'm
still going to give him a run for the
money yeah yeah
and the Franco
what Spencer needs in a number two is a
chef who combines teamwork and cooking
ability and you chef may be arriving all
right yeah it is clearly obvious that
both you and Gary
come stay
one of you will have to go
and I think you should stay
well
to see that and when the new head chef
arrives I think it's going to be a good
recipe for success
but we need to keep that authenticity of
that Italian style that rustic feel of
the walnut tree that's you
I don't know what we'll learn from them
stay here don't you well I would like to
stay here
it was something changed here
it's a hard decision though Gary and
Stefano both have things going for them
I'm convinced their father would make a
better second chef but will Francesco
agree I doubt it well that's interesting
yeah one thing I have learned over the
last few days is they can't work
together total impossibility yeah okay
definitely definitely not but
they can cook and they can put food on
the plate but coming together as a team
you know they haven't got enough respect
for one another but one will have to go
one definitely is my my big concern is
Gary He's not a team player but someone
like Stefano
would sit and be a great number two
you've worked with them both yeah which
one would you have to get rid of in this
case uh I have to go for garlic at last
Francesca and I agree on something
stefana should stay as Spencer's number
two and Gary should go
I'll leave Francesco to sort that one
out
I'm off
hi guys hi you guys continue talking all
right yes don't stop you stay at the
kitchen please yeah continue working on
those customers yes I will yeah keep on
talking to Franco by the wings yeah good
man we'll be back in a month's time okay
um just before I go one little present
very good yes a special gift one of
those filthy Barnacle muscles they
served in my first day yeah sure bye
guys see you in a month's time
[Music]
[Applause]
it's February and I'm back in Wales to
visit the Walnut Tree Inn a month ago I
spent a week here trying to turn things
around and let me tell you it was a hell
of a week
I found a renowned restaurant going bust
[Music]
very important it needed a new head chef
I can't read a joke like that can cook
they were hard Graft in the kitchen you
shut it okay back in your corner and
listen to what's going on do you know
what I said
do it cheaper food
is that a typing error 70 quid and
more was in danger of losing the
Luster's reputation not to mention his
precious Mission start this
establishment I didn't have to learn how
to taste properly understand what
balance of flavor's about
now I'm back to see what's changed the
2004 Michelin guide was published a few
weeks ago sadly the walnut tree lost its
star yeah very well sorry to hear about
the mission style yeah big blow that one
we're getting back we're gonna get it
back
could you go see the bunnies yeah
Spencer yeah
Spence has been here for two weeks but
with no head chef for nearly a year it
was pretty obvious they'd lose their
star hi Spence morning pretty well yeah
so now the question is does Spencer have
the ambition to win it back what about
the mission staff well he's less
pressure because now I just gotta get
back now you can really stand your yeah
mark on it you can now rebuild it and
take the place right down the line as
opposed to yeah at least I can say then
it's mine and I've not taken it over
very well and gives you a chance to
change things as well yes because I
think setting Stone now short yeah
nice very good huh looking very clean
very vibrant and um table 15 yes that
looks lovely huh
do salmon lunch two no starters two
roast beef one fish cake one lasagna
they're all lunch that's a small one
yeah
has he managed to stay out of the
kitchen
um yes and he hasn't come in with his
jacket on not yet yeah that's good news
you don't want him back in the kitchen
do you no no no that's why I've made
desserts more difficult so he doesn't
know what he's doing yeah that's why I
had to change the menu straight away one
super mozzarella two chickens
vibrant action Hey
Kevin sorry come back shouting
um communication and then just a drizzle
with lemon oil Fantastical of course
that's what that is that food's looking
nice food is looking nice and we're
improving every day so it feels more
together already in that short period of
time because he's commanding the kitchen
they follow him that's the most
important thing
I'm surprised to see Gary's still in the
kitchen
we've been told off yet
uh no I can't [__] wait to hear how
that goes down you know that I don't
know actually I was late I was late for
work you're late and did he give you a
bowl of kick oh yeah so you pin me to
the floor and beat me up fantastic
fantastic fantastic
it turns out Stefan doesn't want to
leave he said he's found the change he's
hard to take
I'm quite jealous
Spencer because he's allowed to do
everything
and things that I couldn't even think
about it when I just arrived and uh
that's one of the things that makes me
go away because it is
painful for me to to save
what's going on I wonder how Gary feels
about Stefano's decision to leave so
um
Stefan is leaving yeah was that you
pushed him out no it wasn't me to push
them out no I see it as if um Spencer's
been given the opportunity to do
whatever he likes change the menu
rearrange the kitchen it's been given
all the opportunities and to be able to
go ahead with it yeah which is a bit of
a surprise which is a bit of surprise
Francesco never let Stefano do any of
that he always had the same what was
going on and how how everything
developed yeah and I
suspense are doing all these different
things now and I see Savannah how hard
it was for him to actually take control
of the kitchen it was difficult does
that upset you it doesn't upset me so
much I think it's upset so far no more
than me but you're stronger than Stefano
yeah some of us got to survive on the
others
so there's no room
I'm genuinely sorry that Stefan is
leaving but I'm thrilled Francesco's
back where he belongs
Charming the customers
the dining room's busy and vibrant just
like the old walnut tree now it'll make
sure you put this on the wall look nice
little momentum so when the customers
come through they can see there's four
happy smiling faces yeah yeah
there is a new force in the kitchen in
other words it's a new
and a new Force outside because that's
that's where I belong
being outside and be able to explain and
be confident in what I'm explaining to
the customers
regain that confidence that was once
lost
bye-bye thank you very much
I really do hope that this place gets
back to where it was it's a phenomenal
restaurant you've got a great owner
beautiful dining room great kitchen
and let's get it back
on track
yeah and Spence what do you want to do
in the next two years what's your
ambition at the walnut tree over the
next two years to beat the reputation it
had before you're 26 years of age I was
26 when I got my first HF job
and now at the age of 37 11 years on the
most important job in my entire life at
the age of 26. so good luck
ciao ciao thank you guys thank you yes
the future's definitely looking bright
up for Francesco if he sticks to what I
told him he can make the walnut tree
famous again and win back that Michelin
star
s
[Music]
nothing
thank you very much indeed all the best
bye sir that's it this week I'm trying
to save more place restaurants
[Music]
the dining room's empty where is
everybody
food is shocking
that is a pile of [__] I have to deal
with possibly the worst waiter in the
world
crazy Frenchman you're being a little
[__] again I'm not a chef obsessed
with deep fat Friars with Mark bangs on
again about the justification to why I
should accept that he cooks 99 of these
food with a [__] deep fat fryer I'll
put one up his ass sideways
Asia in the home counties
full of stock Brokers lady Zoo lunch and
golfers
000 rounds of golf are played every year
on isha's more place golf course that
should be more enough to keep the
attached restaurant full but none of the
golfers ever go nor does anyone else
I've never seen such a sorry looking
dining room
I have just the weed to turn the place
around and that's a tall order
Jesus Christ the wife and monstrosity
um First Impressions yeah
um yeah I'll turn it into an open prison
for young offenders because it looks
[__] ghastly
I think this could be my toughest job
yet
[Applause]
come to try out the food
more purple everywhere but the place is
deserted
looks like I'm dining alone not a good
sign
[Music]
God knows what they're going to serve me
deep fried Camembert have I gone back in
time then offer we're about to receive
may I not be poisoned for the fourth
time in four months
amen
Jesus
it reminds me of romantic fish fingers
that's disgusting thank God I've got
some wine to wash it down God there it
is
it absolutely stinks it's caught
where is everybody
still at least I can be sure no one's
watching me
yeah
next up huge
I have gone back in time it's the
coloring equivalent of flared trousers
this duck tastes like it grew up in the
1970s it's not exactly [__] tender
it's a popular dish alone
not really
have a little taste
it's quite tough no
yeah I know you should have always been
out no are you gonna swallow yeah
[Music]
it's still in there
you're so cute
oh my God
horrible food no wonder this place is in
trouble
Clueless
completely clueless
but on the verge of being embarrassing
hmm so what do you think about your meal
tonight
I'm lost for words
almost
nailed up
laughs
well at least I wasn't poisoned so I've
come back to meet the owners of this
1970s nightmare
try to be nice huge place
Richard Hodgson and Nick White House
have sunk all their money into this
place and it's been a disaster
[Music]
it's like an old country House hotel
isn't it historically it was someone's
house this empty room will be costing
them nearly a hundred pounds an hour for
staff and overheads so your potential so
it's fantastic he's got character yeah
it used to be a successful Bernie in in
the days when states were Posh they used
to do 200 250 covers a day here valet
parking and it's probably the last time
it took his real money it was probably
the only restaurant yeah absolutely
aren't they ashamed to be still serving
the same food from The Bernie end days
and who's got the food background
neither of us too our backgrounds drink
um I spent 15 years in the license trade
Richard sacrificed everything to buy
this place if I can't help him his
family can be homeless I should have
done this in my 20s when I didn't have
children and didn't have a huge mortgage
and everything else we both sat there
and thought shall we do it shall we do
it in a few dark nights and we thought
maybe it's a bit risky and there's a lot
of risk involved for us both Nick's put
everything he's got into the business as
well
Running a Restaurant is completely
different from selling drinks no wonder
the kitchen is such a nightmare hey
Hog's missed Irvine was the French head
chef when they took over
but no one liked his cooking including
me
we gave people some shocking experiences
I think it's safe to say well we taught
them what the extremes were like
people can be quite emotional about food
and you've ruined my life that type of
thing I know how they feel
um engine room kitchen yeah good
afternoon let's meet the rest of the
kitchen team and tomorrow Mark Robinson
calls himself the executive chef
whatever that means so your head chef
somewhere else before we came here I
trained as a chef and then
Business Degree
gave up cooking for a business degree
doesn't sound very passionate about food
to me
he was brought in to sort things out but
all he's done is spent thousands of
pounds on microwaves and fryers and piss
survey off come on strawberry French man
hey what's your day
good and he said he doesn't like you
there are two people in the dining room
let's see if their lunch is as bad as my
dinner
almost everything seems to be deep fried
and the oil smells like it hasn't been
changed for months have any walks
through the rest of the further you can
smell is like a tainted fried smell it
was a little bit like hospital food yes
Chef why doesn't anchovy fillets and the
salads he's like going off with his
their own how many new potatoes around
uh only one one new potato yeah [__]
out for nine pound fifty any olives no
nothing's ready here no beans cooked no
eggs what is going wrong well we're just
in the [__] because we've got two
customers for lunch this kitchen is a
nightmare Mount was brought in to update
the food but I can't see what he's done
how can he get away with a menu like
this and how would you um how would you
describe the style food
and it's um
the the the the a la carte stuff that we
do it's very um
it's very much
is a steak and three sauces you can have
with it it's not a great it's not a
massive detraction for what they were
serving before here and three sources of
what uh Brandy and mushrooms Stilton and
bacon
Jesus
those three sauces sound a little bit
Bernie Nish well they are I mean this is
the thing it's a bit it's a bit 1976. do
you could say that again
when you saw straight out the microwave
it's an insult to cooking oh in a bag
damn
no wonder we need so many [__]
microwaves
are they
playing [__] I'm not hungry
parsley hey come on we'll be the same
without pasta come on get it on there
there you go
good old Burley I know you love your
parsley
and so far they need a [__] rock up
their ass because if they continue the
way they are doing now it's going to go
down like a sack of [__] and quite
frankly I don't think they actually care
about customers and every dining room
needs to care about customers otherwise
they don't come [__] back
it's my second day in Asia where I'm
trying to help the more Place restaurant
and Golf Club
the food's stuck in the 70s
as usual there are no customers
today Emmy's book for lunch
nothing and tonight
none so we did have someone come in to
look at the restaurant it's either here
or TGI's I'd rather go to tji's
Mark Robertson the executive chef should
be tearing his hair out but he's taking
the day off
you look different out your wives
you look like a monk on leave
[Laughter]
thanks I'm going to play golf later
around
going to play golf
supposed to be running an empty
restaurant to get it off the ground to
get it moving towards something
semi-decent it's not [__] around on a
golf course at least he knows there's
something wrong because he's hired a new
head chef now there are three talk about
too many cooks one's a joke Frenchman
the other's stuck in the 70s I hope Andy
trial from the 21st century you've
really got your work cut out there I
know and you can't go in with all guns
blazing putting them all in the Ghoulies
in the first 24 hours you'll have no one
left I know I know how would you how
would you play this situation narrow the
menu down to begin with yeah start off
really simple yeah um and and look
what's going on locally Andy looks
promising but I have to show him what
he's up against
what is that
Jesus when you're right painful it's
like a dehydrated silicone pot actually
it's a microwave frozen deep-fried
burger what is that this is a salad
looks like a plate of worms
got to break my heart when I see this
[__] you know that okay do you think
that's nice yeah
it's not bad Andy's worked at some
really good places he's going to need
all his experience I know I know it's
instantly simple any sauce in a jar
[Music]
[__] customers
yes you're being a little [__] again
how could we have a Frenchman in here
and we're buying French dressing room
I'm impressed so far with Andy he seems
Keen to make changes
yeah this is what I want to get away and
they put it on the menu as Brussel Pate
Brussels with chicken yeah it's just
plastic crap yeah
now they're definitely left on the
Bernie end
Frozen Yorkshire pudding oh lovely Andy
could be the chef I've been looking for
and that means I can get out of the
kitchen and work with the owners
it looks like a deceased Bridge Club why
spend ten thousand pounds painting the
building a horrible color and nothing on
improving the food the reason for doing
it was to show people that the place had
changed under that it was very different
yeah at night though we launched it up
with purple lighting it looks fantastic
but it is probably alienated some of our
old Core Business the most important
thing is to focus on the food and get
the food up to where it should be what
we should be offering local how we
should be selling the food and and
bringing in a bit of a bit of a bargain
I'm taking Richard down the High Street
to find out where his ex-customers are
eating
I can't believe how close together the
Russians are yeah really remember one
High Street
is made up of wealthy City types ladies
at lunch and surprisingly thousands of
Americans who work for a big
conglomerate in the area and no Peppers
drinking champagne yeah
it's churning all the time you know
there's a good example yeah very good
Richard's a businessman and I want him
to see how much money these places are
taken
there are 23 restaurants on the High
Street so competition is fierce
but I bet most people don't even know
there's a Russian and more place a quick
challenge I'm gonna ask a family I'm
gonna stop them and say have you heard
of more place you know what it is do you
know where it is and come and try us for
lunch have you heard of your place
we heard of more place you haven't
you've heard of more places here up the
road there have you been have you used
the place before no I don't know
it's strikes he's been an idol another
purple building there it's a funeral
directors
yes well before they painted it's um a
strange color you're not a fan of the
color no it was painted differently
tomorrow would you come back next week
I'll get two brushes you can have one of
them
so in a survey on the color
I think this Trip's opened his eyes to
the potential of his own restaurant just
give me an idea for the new menu the
plan is to give the Russian a new
Direction and get people talking about
more place the deep fried [__] has to go
and the party around the plates and the
chopped tomato and that that that's
[__] 70s crap at its best Gordon I
have no desire to spend the rest of my
working day smelling of fat there's
there's you know thousands of Americans
that live locally that is the most
amazing Market to tap into there's no
reason why you can't have not an
American themed restaurant but an
American influence but getting the place
famous for two or three dishes when
someone's driving past it oh Christ look
there's more place you know they've got
the best burger in Asia yeah it gives a
[__] it's a talk point where there's the
best burger whether it's the best
chowder it doesn't matter but as usual
Mark has a problem
my concern is how that would go down
with
um any of the older clientele okay is
that keeping the business afloat no no
there you go no disrespect yeah I've got
interactions before where everyone would
be nervous about the existing old farty
boring bastards that sit there and take
a two-week holiday in between courses
and dribble throughout the Viagra are
coming with a coffee we're looking for
new vibrant young exciting customers
that are going to be loyal to this place
for the next 10 years can we [__] off in
the kitchen now absolutely
stay focused One Direction American
Style Cafe upbeat friendly service
plenty good food and stick to it and if
Mark bangs on again about the
justification to why I should accept
that he cooks 99 of his food in a
[__] deep fat fryer and to why they
spent what 12 and a half thousand pounds
on six [__] microwaves I'll put one
up his ass sideways
[Music]
uh why don't we do a couple of burgers
up for uh Richard and Nick my organic
burger made with totally fresh
ingredients is miles away from Mark's
deep fried crab nothing wrong with a
burger
[Music]
welcome to proper cooking and it's
cheaper to make than bought in Silicon
implants tomato chutney it's a nice raw
cherry tomato chutney with shallots I
put a little bit of Parmesan on toast
them
the celebration Burger lovely
so far Nick and Richard have shown
little interest in the food they're
serving
[Music]
what's the verdict
that's fantastic absolutely
brilliant it's just that's the talking
point that is I took more place and the
burgers are awesome you've got to go
there and have one fresh meat cheese
and because burgers are traditionally so
badly done we've got an opportunity to
really Excel
I can almost see them counting the money
they could make with my American theme
burgers and corned beef hash pecan pie
Peach Melba and smoked Havoc Chowder the
most important thing about this
particular soup is that you know it's
done up in the morning clam chowder made
up using potatoes clam juice thicken it
we've got a little step further and
poached some quail eggs then pour
the Chowder over the haddock over the
clams
they're quite like it's still nice and
running inside
that's moist
the food is really coming together let's
see the corn beef with holidays finished
with plumbing mustard not difficult
finally we're getting somewhere now all
we need is some customers
55 000 golfers use this place every
bloody year you know that and there's a
small percentage of them actually get in
for that Bloody restaurant through there
so the idea now is going around there
stalk them a little bit on the green and
ask them to taste this amazing fruit I'm
taking Kim one of the waitresses and
Andy to entice them in with the food
morning sir how you doing
sir thank you very much what is he made
of that is a night of Handy Chef in the
restaurant at more place are you we
haven't used it I've been in that place
for three years four years now I used to
come down this on a Sunday and we booked
a breakfast and we had a tea books and
they just took so long to get their
breakfast there really that's
interesting well uh we had to tee off
and had to leave the breakfast and I've
been in there since Nick and Richard
can't keep an empty restaurant going
forever we have to fill the dining room
and make customers come back this is a
beautiful mini hamburger with a nice
fresh tomato chutney on top charcoal
grilled would you miss the kind to have
a quick taste and just give it a little
inside yeah pleasure
people into the restaurant trying my
good food is there a theme to your menu
chowder
um great Burgers corned beef hash uh
beautiful roast
um Knickerbocker glories would you come
back to the Russians
there are three days of the year and all
restaurants however bad are full New
Year's Eve Valentine's night and
Mother's Day what are you doing on
Mother's Day
that's a good point it's Mother's Day
this Sunday and it could be make or
break from more place or maybe book a
table for Mother's Day weekend Sunday
you can pie it's uh slightly heavier on
the run which makes it a little bit
special this is nice possibly tries out
one day we will try you out thank you
definitely
three down 34
997 to go
hopefully we've enticed some disgruntled
customers back and made some new
converts my next task to sort out the
waiters
all nine of them
it's Andy's night off and so Mark's
running the kitchen yeah
Peter it's not Square yeah just Square
them up so why is he in the dining room
I just want them straight tonight I want
to see if the waiters can push the new
menu on a bed of spinach topped with a
fried egg oh well that sounds great
actually it is nice I tried it yesterday
well done Kim one corned beef hash let's
start with the spinach next time okay
quick smoke
which is a soup it's with the with the
with the come on Peter
he's got hot dog fish he's got he's got
uh what was the attack it was perfect no
the customers know more than him can I
have the come on bed two of those oh God
they've ordered the Camembert
just okay your jacket looks so shy I'm
not sure he can walk and talk at the
same time
never mind sell the new menu there you
go that's it
now things are going wrong in the
kitchen as well Mark can't even make the
deep fried Camembert it's frozen I
thought it was his specialty
thank you
but they're full of platinum if it's
under ripe cheese then it'll be a lot
harder to get running even because of
the Frozen it's never going to go
running because it's not right
now the chef's going to the dining room
that's pretty much one member of staff
for every two customers
and there are no vegetables in the main
course and they need my help to serve
them how are they ever gonna manage with
more than nine customers
I think they've touched so far on this
evening
looking Overcoat undercooked
unripened deep-fried Camembert and
I'm really worried this dining room will
be full on Sunday they can be as many as
150 customers we don't stand a chance
and if it continues to go like it is now
maybe more [__] Camembert inside the
pot plants
really [__] shocking
dining room absolutely crucial we can't
do without you and you can't do without
us and we've got to establish that
teamwork and we've got to come together
as a team
and think together as a team and then
never forget the most important person
is the customer
so it's a very straightforward exercise
Nick and I are going to arrive
in the dining room for the first time
we've got a table book for 1 30 for
lunch today ready
sit me down present the menu and sell me
this restaurant here we go Peter's been
here for 15 years so he should know what
he's doing
good afternoon Mr Whitehurst nice to see
you Mr Ramsey
long time to see you I've got a nice
table for you yeah well you can't fool
his enthusiasm
still a sparkling for both of you
sparkling for me sparkling um I'll have
a beer actually
Kim's been a waitress for five years
she's Charming but has no real training
a beer bitter bitter okay the lamb
perhaps lamb uh yeah Zach's only been
here a week he knows nothing really
nothing where's it from the left I'm not
too sure thank you
um oh soup of the day not too sure
either I'm sorry
still spoken yes still but still uh
what's special
we have less than 48 hours to master the
new menu and be able to sell it to the
customers
seafood soup is good it's got some White
Fish there he's got Cocos Cocos
this is going to be harder than the
kitchen I used to work as a waiter and
I'm sure I can show them how it's done
smoked had a chatter beautiful creamy
soup garments with flakes of oat smoke
how to finish with a wonderful poached
quality so nice beef chowder beef
chowder definitely not we also have a
special on today clam chowder the
Chowder the child is a very nice platter
it's very nicely blatter nice short
descriptive idea of the special clam
chowder very strong tasting I'm turning
[__] gray I have to be the meningo
for the menu but I'll give I'll give the
menu to you there you go okay hold on
let me see what we got last time sharp
tasting got a special twist to it as we
put a whale's head in it or Quail Zed in
it much better Quail said in it really
did even my pubes are going great
garnished with The Oaks of haddock flake
sorry garnished
can you cook no this whole thing is
theater and this fashion has to become a
showcase and each and every customer is
going to eat in here on Sunday gearing
up for a bloody busy day has to remember
you yes and if they remember you and we
served good food boy are they going to
come back and one last chance for Zach
here we go this one I can feel in my
bones I can see how relaxed you are
you're looking good you're cool you're
dude give it to me the the smoked
haddock Charlie is a very nice dish um
it has a nice creamy fishy garnished
with Flakes and a nice smoked haddock in
the middle he's selling like cupcakes
it would be funny if it wasn't for
Mother's Day oh [__] I've only been like
two days to prepare though so it's like
oh [__] you know you've got two days to
prepare one [__] speech I've got 24
hours to get a [__] mission ready
Zach
I'm more than halfway through my time
and more place the food's better the
waiters have improved but without any
customers it's all a bit pointless
there are three days of the year when
every Russian should be full even purple
ones New Year's Eve Valentine's Day and
Mother's Day and Sunday is Mother's Day
Richard and Nick have been taking
bookings trying to pull back some money
table plan good news is what we've got
11 books
now we've got quite a bit more than that
but hit me with it
181. [__] confirmed I should be pleased
but I'm terrified I thought we'd
struggle with 150 but 181. it's making
me feel worried slightly bit ambitious
yeah
but just yeah what we're trying to do
and turn this place around
the division yeah and getting customers
in here but and what worries me is that
you know they're still not turned on
female putting off more than I can do
with the amount of covers they want to
do
I'm as worried as Andy but I have an
idea roast chicken just like your mother
used to make but with a Twist carve at
the table to take pressure off the
kitchen you've got a chicken before I
know you've got a chicken before no
you've got a chicken before many many
years many many years
Rich at home of course everyone's going
to learn including the owners Jason you
thought you were coming down here for
around the golf no you're not I want you
to do a chicken ready yeah I've brought
in JC one of my best maitre D's he knows
everything there is to know about
service and about carving a chicken I
mean one of the classic
we do first cut off the legs
then separate the drumstick from the
thigh
next cut along the breastbone keep the
knife close to the carcass and take off
the breast
I will I will just be myself yes yes
and the customer can do what what you
want yeah so we do one breast one one
there
turn the chicken over and remove the
succulent oyster underneath that's a
nice little piece of meat
on Sunday
4.50 an hour no no we'll push the boats
come on time for everyone to practice
the legs are first
and then you go on to the breast the
chicken has to be carved in three
minutes or the rest of the food will
have gone cold it doesn't look like a
chicken
cut the drum off we've got the thigh
there yeah
you're just having problems with the
breasts yeah tomorrow I have to carve in
front of the customers and it'll have to
look better than this
it's like the [__] foxes attacked it
the chickens are coming on and it'll be
so nice to have chickens carved at the
table and they're getting the waiters to
take some pressure off our [__]
shoulders on Sunday with Gratton dolphin
wars in the bowl on the table yeah yeah
um fresh peas because it's just coming
to season yeah perfect and so that's the
major selling point yeah for the dining
room and pecan pie instead of being
positive about Mother's Day Mark's
worrying about old customers who are
expecting the 1970s menu he's already
sent out the people have booked have
seen this yeah it has long as they know
they're going to get the beef lamb
chicken Graces they may have seen the
menu but they haven't [__] tasted it
yeah absolutely so that's one big
[__] relief for me straight away I
really want Mark to be right behind the
changes I respect how many we got booked
we're going to be in this [__] big time
and if we can entice 25 of these
customers on Sunday to return you know
oh we've got them yeah you've got them
the simple truth is that Nick and
Richard have got greedy and overbooked
they have to learn to care for their
customers do you think you're both now
capable of running a restaurant as
you've said before and as we've not made
any bones about we're not food experts
we're not restaurant operators our
backgrounds drink
um
so we've undoubtedly got lots and lots
to learn I think we need to be in here
certainly in the shorts medium term we
need to keep to building our capability
if you are going to go up a division and
take it from Center strength you have to
get firmer I have to do it every day
because there's a part of me that thinks
Christ you nasty bastard and now that
you guys have physically hands on I mean
really Hands-On it'd be so good to keep
control of it hold tight to those
[__] Reigns if Richard and Nick are
serious about getting stuck in we could
still get through Mother's Day I'm going
to take them out their word and give
them some real work to do
I really wish I could repaint the
building for tomorrow but at least I can
do something about the inside so when
you walk in here first thing you look at
is a little bit disorientated because
you're confused to wear the ration is at
the moment the customers are in danger
of getting lost on the way into the
dining room
walk through down to the right and then
when you come into here it's such a
lovely area here and what I was thinking
see all these parts that side yeah let's
get this over here a little bit of
screen yeah okay maybe one of those
Dominion streams sectioned off and it
just gives a nice smooth clear flow
through if you don't catch them they
often feel they often Mill around here
yeah it's like it's almost disorientated
yeah come through this door walk in
first thing you see horrible plastic
Cold Ground so the area outside the
restroom just as important as inside
very warm and it's even more intriguing
now than it is when you walk through the
everything is ready for Mother's Day
just one last test to see if Richard can
carve the chicken in less than three
minutes three minutes
laughs
how you feeling
have you started
I'm a feeling yeah overwhelmed when we
started
I've even practiced it I'm only at home
every hour of every minute of every day
four minutes ago
he's done it Richard's ready to face his
customers
well done
can I just say that we've got 50 roast
chickens for tomorrow to sell [__]
let me think that's a hundred legs that
could go into someone's laughing
good morning guys the big day has
arrived and if you're going to give the
diners A Mother's Day to Remember we
better get cracking
how many chickens are going in six
chickens down that down the oven there
we've got a chicken in there and then
I've got that whole tray of chickens
here as well as roast chicken Andy's
cooking a rib eye beef with all the
trimmings and hervey he's in charge of
the Yorkshire puddings
perfect
you cannot make Yorkshire pudding like
this
[__] hell not exactly how your mother
made them they're like bullets maybe you
have to cook them longer as well yeah
and and hotter to start off with just to
get them Rising morning oh you got 15
chickens
be nice you could do 10 of them
well me personally yeah thanks for that
I'm going to start to think about
chicken
okay here we go
Yoshi puddings
what do you reckon
50 50.
fingers crossed
if my York's puddings rise the kitchen
will be almost ready
Just One Last pep talk for the waiters I
just want you to stop crashing around
move around the dining room like a
ballerina you can see that wonderful
floor out there you just treat that like
it's Swan Lake gliding in and out all
the tables
if we get this right more players will
really take off if not we'll offend half
the mothers in Isha
oh we shouldn't be under this pressure
on [__] Mother's Day
okay and just stay there two seconds no
no no no no no
does it go and knock them down look at
everybody standing here away from my
[__] [__] off out of here
oh [__] now
come on up one more look just in case I
was imagining things ready
your problem there we go
right come here please
okay ridges look that's what I'm trying
to explain that's the Yorkshire pudding
that's a pile of [__] yes right where's
that fresh little [__] come here all
right
end the story
okay 50 minutes to go first tables are
wearing a 12 o'clock quarter um I need
to leave for the kitchen yeah okay
um starters smoked haddock chowder is a
creamy fish soup garnished with Oak
smoked haddock main courses roast
chicken half their table that's down to
you guys push the chicken traditional
roast beef Yorkshire puddings
price what do you think this time last
week we went from two to 180 for lunch
today
so I'm gonna be in the dining room right
behind them give them a little bit of
support
because I think the kitchen's pretty
much set we're there but dining room's
still
a little bit apprehensive
[Music]
bookings have been staggered over two
sittings so we'll be working for six
hours straight
after Zach's performance with the
Chowder I put him on bar Duty
[Music]
Kim Nick Richard and Peter will be
working the floor
and he's in charge of the kitchen with
irvo has his right hand man
you've got three minutes over here how
many is it four how many is the chicken
four four and the executive chef well
yeah he's in charge of Crockery okay
and it tastes brilliant it will do Nick
the world are good to meet some
customers the burgers are selling well
but at the moment not enough chicken
just two or three of you want the
chicken I'm gonna bring out your table
and cold for you on the table
it's not one to try so um
they actually sell one chicken the rest
of the dining will start to see sort of
a little bit of excitement a little bit
of magic happening around the table so
they'll All-Star ordering which then
within an hour will run out which is
exactly what we need now there's a nice
Buzz coming out of the room
it sounds really
happy
here he comes give it to me
chicken for four
rice chicken after all my doubts it's
Peach who sold the first chicken
sure enough soon everyone wants one
[Music]
makes you feel a bit more hungry
I think of the drumstick well it's not
bad I've never seen that in there
do you want a bit of age yeah that's
fine
relax there's only a chicken
everybody's rising to the occasion and
the first city was going really well
[Music]
two
there you are thank you it's great to
see the dining room full and feel the
buzz
but on the second sitting the other
bookings causing a problem there are
just too many people
there's a table of 19 and a table of 15
and a 14 pretty much come in at the same
time and it's not very good when you've
got like 48 people all at once because
they shouted the kitchen
Nick and Richard have to learn a
cardinal rule put the customers first
make them feel really special and build
a sense of loyalty I don't expect to
come out for a family meal I have to
wait as long as this it's not a question
of fast food it's a question now we've
been an hour and a half we've got a
starter that's it I'm not having a lot
of explanation other than we've been
really busy yeah we've kept cheerful
haven't we except for Colin still here
we are we learn and we don't come back
again have you ever had a chicken carved
at your table no well I've not done this
many times Kim's trying her best but
Charming the customers just won't work
they want to eat
remember unhappy customers destroy
reputations
wait how the [__] can you cook for
nearly 50 people at one time yeah
[Music]
the food was very good yeah the rest of
it the structure the organization I'm
sorry mate
waiting stuff I mean the girls but you
know she's the only one that dies in the
black shirts and everything that we're
the managers they were sitting down
talking to their mates in the
conservatory there and they only left
two people serving everybody else in
here
let's hope Richard and Nick learn their
lesson the dining room's empty now but
it's been full for the first time in a
long time and the vast majority of
customers went away happy
one chicken left okay
well done
thank you yes
happy
yeah it's good working with Andy yeah
will you use my recipe for Yorkshire
puddings
then the bloody French
don't don't mind you up for the last
minute
oh come on we got to the end of the day
we're gonna have some fisticus before we
go everyone performed in the kitchen
and the waiters did a great job I'm
really impressed with the way everyone
pulled together
that was fantastic and you're running
around crazy today like proud [__] wow
this is fun this is heat and this is
buzzing hey I'm running it I'm happy
with Larry since we started we've never
had a day like we've had today in here
and you know what
quarter to 12. lunchtime I don't think
you're going to do because I didn't
think any of you were good enough to do
it one complaint was the fact that the
food was taking too long and the rest of
the complaints were just
customers arriving again
still not happy with that Bloody color
that purple monstrosity
let's hope we put more plays back on the
map
[Applause]
[Music]
when I first arrived at Moore place I
found a restaurant in crisis
where is everybody it felt more like a
rest home today Abby's book for lunch
nothing food was deep fried microwaved
or out of a packet that's [__] 70s
crap at its best too many cooks and not
one of them any good are they thank [__]
I'm not hungry
and I met possibly the worst waito in
the world oh Zach I'm [__] I mean
really [__] shocking but by the end
of the week things had started to
improve
now I'm back to see what's changed
oh [__] it's still purple apart from the
horrible color my biggest problem was
with the executive chef I couldn't see
the point
are you not wearing a chef's jacket
but at least he's staying out of the
kitchen get hold of Andy missing you
already yeah right
it's the first day of Andy's new menu
morning guys
Sean Irvine how are you
still happy as ever miserable [__] how
are you you're well Andy how are you
yeah good thanks how many new dishes
you've got going on tonight
chicken Marina six stars I've taken some
of your ideas and added some of my own
ideas as well but yeah it's got the
haddock chowder Waldorf salad that we've
done on Mother's Day Burger how's that
going yeah it's going very well very
well oh here he is
potato and chips on me yeah that's it
that's it yeah
don't start bringing in your saute
potatoes and stuff like that pizza that
is all the vegetarians in the 15 years
he's worked here he'd have never seen so
many changes Peter still good to see you
being the ultimate pain in the ass
these look nice Christ almighty nice
little um apple tarts whatever taste one
yeah how much they cost to make pounds
yeah if that pizza Apple's hard crispy I
hope you can taste the difference in the
fresh food delusions isn't that better
than that Frozen [__] that you can
served a month ago lovely this place
just not only looks different it smells
different you think so yeah it just
smells sort of fresh fresh yeah the
front's still purple
that's true
oh the staff causing any problems are
they he seems to be working out right
he's a bit negative but once you show
him how to do something and see you get
him on your way of thinking then uh yeah
he can see the improvements maybe bullet
Mark yet yeah today oh good
how's Zach doing smoking had a child and
look at him look at that give it to me
send it to me remember it quickly it's a
it's a creamy fish soup garnished with a
flakes of Oak haddock and a nice quiet
leg in the middle my God he can do it
let's hope Andy doesn't change the menu
too soon thanks Zach okay new menu a new
start and is exactly what this place
needs uh more place Burger we have um
seared salmon and it's on a champ Mash
they cook for 181 guests on Mother's Day
and everyone went away happy apart from
a table of 19.
hope Richard and Nick have learned from
that it's all twos threes four sixes
there's no nine teams or anything like
that it's all nice good easy stuff uh 27
whether there's 20 customers or 200 the
servers has got to match the food let's
keep it nice for tonight one last thing
it really breaks my heart when uh I've
put sauce and everything on the plate
and the waiters come along and they fold
the plates up their arms see if the
sauce is nice and thick but I mean so
sometimes the sauce
no two chicken Maryland one french fries
one veg thank you
we've got a new um head chef who started
about four weeks ago hopefully you'll
stay it's good to see Nick engaging with
customers
Andy would you recommend I have for
dinner
I quite like the lamb
I like the sound of the um salmon as
well special yeah have we sold any yet
yeah we sold uh sold three
the wages look like they're enjoying
their jobs and getting excited about the
new food
service
nice Buzz tonight okay yeah really nice
Buzz
presentation looks nice yeah it's simple
unfussy
I've never been a big fan of fried leaks
but that's a garnish are you both happy
so far with the sort of American
restaurant but the theme side to the
food
yes yeah um I'd love to see far more
bombs on Seas I think the biggest thing
for me has been we've actually got
somebody
that cash as much as we do about the
business the staff said on Sunday it was
probably the first time they'd ever
taken food out that they knew wasn't
coming back
yeah
thank you they've got a real asset in
Andy
we never ever
restaurateurs we're not the new two guys
that have got the potential to go all
the way provided you remove yourself
from the best mates scenario for the
staff I start tidying the screws a
little bit you guys are smart Kim's
smart then I get Friar Tuck walking in
with a [__] scruffy t-shirt on and a
pair of jeans look at him now that table
in agreement with you
this is about discipline Richard and
it's very hard to implement discipline
when you're so close to these guys the
Russian's not full every night but
Turner is already up 20
superb
100 guests going through a day six days
a week turning you know 18 20 grand a
week alone I I swear to God you guys
have got a [__] gold mine on your
hands can I just show you one more thing
no no I want to show you how to play
[__] golf
would you like me to play to put some
film on the pond so when it splashes in
there we don't hear it
great to see the dining room busy and
the Russian making money at last if Nick
and Richard can attract as many
customers as they get on their Golf
Course then more plays can be a big
success
they're going to be so bright like that
so you can actually see them whiz
through the air do they float
we'll see
oh I've got one left
and that was a [__] [__] shot but I
played a lot worse and you know what
it's like me inviting you to my
restaurant I'm [__] your omelette
that's what it's like Pringle pans
Pringles socks Pringle jumper Pringle
glove all the gear no idea and no
[__] bollocks
oh look at that beautiful